le théâtre et si pour une fois on
regardait le décor tenait l'événement du
festival d'automne de paris c'est la
pièce de chenilles de l'air le chemin
solitaire vienne au début du siècle bien
sûr nostalgie et rêves brisés évidemment
et pour faire ressortir cette atmosphère
fin de siècle le décor compte beaucoup
vous l'imaginez et bien ce décor on le
doit à richard peduzzi c'est l'un des
plus grands michels trilogie 6 et
patrick voix reportage voici la
discrétion fait homme celui que l'on ne
voit jamais sur le devant de la scène
mais dont le travail
le savoir-faire le style sont inscrits
de bout en bout dans un spectacle voici
richard peduzzi décorateur de théâtre
l'un des grands de ce métier avec
quelques objets et beaucoup
d'imagination ils vous créé tout un
univers gens ont envie d'engager cette
bataille avec l'espace avec le vide
cette mise en lumière de la
signification d'une pièce richard
peduzzi en est partie prenante
il ne se contente pas comme les
décorateurs du siècle dernier
d'illustrés simplement l'action ce type
de décor est terminée ou hisser les
décors qui datent du de la fin du 19e
siècle mais d'ailleurs ce type de décor
là qui date de 1975 a aussi terminé et
parfois les gens sont trompeurs besoins
des décors trop lourd trop cher et
finalement quand c'est trop lourd trop
cher ça se voit et c'est pas bien parce
que quand ça soit trop on passe on est à
côté de la plaque
cette modestie pour être efficace pour
se mettre au service d'un auteur richard
peduzzi la fait sienne une exigence
qu'il l'amène à épurer son travail à en
éliminer le pittoresque le charmant le
dérisoire
afin de ne troublez en rien ce rapport
étrange entre les acteurs et les
spectateurs
très très content d'être avec lui parce
que j'ai l'impression justement ne pas
avoir faire avec quelques hits
décorateur dans le sens décoratif mais
c'est quelqu'un qui peut qui peut
recréer qui invente un lieu
il a beaucoup voyagé mais quand j'avais
dit en vantant de lui une carte richard
peduzzi 6l son entreprise de
mystification
il réussit à nous faire croire pour un
temps que la scène c'est le monde
je n'ai pas d'amis quand j'en ai je les
rognons